[Musique]
la personne s'accorde les chaussures Patrick
avocat corrige le nucléaire a les
missionnaires maladroits ou fait partie intégrante de
l'histoire du Québec leur mission première
convertir les peuples autochtones des provinces
pour les civiliser littéralement régnant sur
leurs âmes et leurs corps soi-disant même
arrêtés laisse ces entités Seigneur notre
méthode  ou l'enquête nous a conduits dans deux
nations huit communautés d'un
village à l'autre nous avons trouvé agresseur
après agresseur
en quelques semaines seulement nous avons pu
documenter les agressions sexuelles commises par
10 Latrice au
fil des ans beaucoup ont dénoncé l'
abus sexuel mais en vain les autorités religieuses
faire la sourde oreille service est-elle de la
sauteuse ne suis-je pas injustement refusé une
nouvelle en première page de non défendu la casa
para ne remplacera pas doucement votre
DFS nous ne savons pas vraiment pourquoi vous n'avez pas
essayé les missionnaires sur  les demandes
d'aide sont restées sans réponse, comme le père
pourrait poursuivre un pédophile chez les femmes tushy qui a
été laissé à lui-même en plus d'
être un regu  lar à l'église a laissé des
enfants autochtones sans défense la communauté cellulaire
un McConnell semble ridicule un
morceau de Covino TDC était ici remède si jamais mais
Cupidon problème voila
[Musique]
nous sommes chez les femmes tushy dans le centre du québec
un chimiste nazi réservé père créatures
piétiner si heureux bazar le
fondateurs celui qui est asif raja kappa
je vois que seul
alex nous ramène à l'endroit
où cooter l'a agressé alors qu'il n'était
qu'un garçon qui était dans les années 1980 l'
apôtre du succès de l'huile d'olive je suis un humble doodle
il avait 6 ans  Je suis bizarre à propos d'un
Jason est aujourd'hui le directeur du
service d'incendie ici quand il est revenu de
ses études, il a été choqué par ce qu'il a
trouvé, c'est que du tout
Kida ce que c'était dans deux chemins différents
c'était pour moi moi tu mec
quoi un autre  la victime ne peut pas être écrasante
bada est tout - merci
certains étaient des amis père kusu un missionnaire maladroit a
agressé au moins une douzaine de
garçons dans cette communauté
tout ce qu'elle fait est de poster un avis sur ma
bouche désolé gamin que le gars c  ured the
from was for the fuselage lotia
vaincu puis une entreprise suppose et père
pourriez-vous savoir exactement comment attirer les
jeunes garçons le fournisseur - auto-assembler
ashtavakra ne saviez-vous pas
qu'il fallait faire quelque chose non Jenna a recommencé à tirer
pensait vouloir  venez écouter dans
un inclus un homme
[Musique]
nous avons dit que nous restons sur Thomas sur la façon dont Alex
sait depuis longtemps qu'Arthur était une autre des
victimes de Cooter mais c'est la première
fois que nous partageons leurs histoires ensemble,
ils trouvent le courage d'affronter le
passé  et revenez avec nous dans les cabines
utilisées par le missionnaire pour attirer sa proie
[Musique]
sur le feu que je joue le fanatisme
Meredith
donc le système de labora est tellement
important alors j'ai vu que je fais répéter
enlever le papier d'aluminium le papier d'aluminium le
piquet fabriqué un peu de colère  tu sais pousser le
lipide ouais fondamentalement comme un massage
Travis je veux dire je me sens un peu obscur
pour que ça nous
- comment chicka wow wow c'est comme un
mercure discrètement italicum et ingénieux les rumeurs d'abu  se joindre
Charles coucou un chef spirituel chez les
femmes deshi qu'il confronte quand ikutsu
publiquement au magasin local Papa mon
point ferait la fête fête
brumeuse fête très pauvre
les anciens les grands-mères et les grands-
pères l'ont soutenu
comme si comme je vais vous rester une
communauté faisant taire efficacement les
villages  les jeunes donc non non non para NC fait
sous la communauté ils disent que le mont Pulag
part c'est mon équipage ouais d'accord s'il
vous plaît votre fille désolé pour aujourd'hui
elle a eu le téléphone portable l'homme
qu'elle a eu lors d'un événement à Uniontown
[Musique]
Arthur a mis sa douleur dans  chanson
J'ai rencontré un enfant marchant ces choses Je
vais vous dire ce qui s'est passé ce qu'ils
m'ont fait wilmarie demande le de me demander
de porter mes orteils à la place marabout un
tuteur l'économie la plus riche la première
valeur Marilla
Stella Beauprez la fois où
Amara s'élève  et odomètre pour vérifier
Amira pour mesurer notre mariage pour savoir
s'il est dû passe sur le haut-parleur oui juste une
personne au hasard et passe donc ce sont
des normes fondamentales Aus  chanson tralian
[Musique]
ici c'est cette chambre pour Marcus je
suppose que bonjour - le laissez-passer peut être détruit
ouais le tissu est la formule X préparation un
remède pour la suite je te poursuis
à ce sujet tu sais P ensemble dit
compé il dit Rita qui empêche sur
quoi  qu'est-ce que nous sommes au courant de votre politique, mais un
e-mail du Ponyo Ponyo be Wonka viens
bientôt être un peu notre navire
qu'avez-vous vendu Alexi mal oh ouais
jouer un [ __ ] tuez-vous une
décennie d'abus les victimes se suicident
et pour ajouter l'insulte à la blessure imaginez qui
a officié les services funéraires ce soir
chercheur singe stupide célébrité gâchis que
les pirates font
pour porter votre programme de toujours manger équitablement
elle le fera et plus vite rien de tel,
elle a embrassé Karen à l'extérieur prendre l'
échantillon c'était précisément le suicide de l'un de
ses mandats qui a conduit le
travailleuse sociale pour affronter les
missionnaires avec cette crise, elle se sent comme ma
soirée d'alto, ma madame du thé pourrait
aller chercher l'homme avec d'autres travailleurs sociaux, a
demandé Koon aux autorités religieuses.  liens pour
supprimer Kuchar mais sans
plainte officielle la congrégation a refusé
sliggoo même un mauvais plan de fête est venu sur
une feuille de façade Silla homme
préparant un rapport idée d'usine que
j'ai atteint quand je pouvais vendre par téléphone
aux points de vente maison de retraite en visuel
vous il admet avoir commis  les abus pour
les jeux avec les garçons crucio dit qu'il a
demandé de l'aide à l'époque notamment
au psychologue des points de vente les
sorties de Mary Michael il n'a réagi qu'une
fois que les rumeurs d'abus étaient sur le
point de devenir publiques
ma mère elle a protesté oh et quoi
l'a-t-il fait l'a-t-
il frappé en France mais il sera coupé
plusieurs années plus tard d'autant plus que
les prêtres publics à venir sont présents avec la
nation chimique de l'Indiana depuis le début du
XXe siècle, en particulier à Man Awan, de nombreux
missionnaires sont passés au fil des
ans, mais trois en particulier
marque de rire agressant sexuellement des femmes
et des enfants sur trois générations
L'histoire de Madeleine neon
Tuan remonte aux années 50 qu'il peut
e  arn son successeur un penseur en non-conformiste
et le port
ils le disent et puis le bâton est tel
qu'il a dit d'accord vous savez ma justification
faites en sorte que certains le terminent donc pénis
[Musique]
la question de l'enceinte est un doii un Noblet
qui a servi dans la marijuana de 1938 à
1953 un ancien exhibitionniste des enfants
troublant d'entendre des hommes et des femmes maintenant des
grands-parents s'exprimer pour la première
fois
Antonio a également décidé de se libérer de
ses religieux vous savez merci voyez
nous vaincre avouez voir la sous-série asana de ma famille
SSR
il y avait une mention d'une soeur  le code est
le petit-neveu d'Antonio quarante ans plus tard,
lui aussi a été agressé par un prêtre Noblet
cette fois c'est Clemont aller au vieux ek
clérical est-ce que vous découvrez une politique il
était directeur du pensionnat point do
à Lexington quand il a
fermé la congrégation l'a envoyé
où il est resté jusqu'à la
politique de Chicago, ce qui nous a amenés à rester un pc del
valle de member sa grand-mère préparait des
repas pour les prêtres et était
chargée de livrer  en les invitant à un lapatin
don't win jewel institute il vengera
les conséquences sont tragiques pour le cloud
can t make with a poem waves
macfay co-frother message file
management on yellow perch in Miami
barrage tu m'as dit qu'une goutte d'
âme n'est pas  un mile jusqu'à l'âme
elle a un orteil Philippines même le pur
Chaka Chaka Mohammed II voulait juste d'
accord c'est bon à voir
de toutes les histoires mais peut partager
avec nous celle concernant l'alma cool du père
était la plus déconcertante qui soit
arrivée dans les années 60  et des années 70 au DN
décrit le rituel des prêtres religieux
ed il s'agit de cette loi de ciment totalement
célèbre hors la loi Bhavan irrépressible osez
dire verrouillez vous apprenez le matériel signez
le passage Anita Lucy a choqué Rocco il l'a
fait à Medellin une fois je dois avouer je
connais la Sicile le jeune chef de MANOWAR est venu
sur mags feuille d'or alors leader de l'
association des indiens du
québec la figure mythique des luttes indigènes
max GUI a vieilli depuis mais c'est toujours
vif d'esprit je m'en souviens aussi  s
rencontre avec les jeunes femmes le
regarde Effendi a dit tranquillement avant que je ne
mette une touche de cuir ils ne croisent que
Patsy suis-je - tais-toi - jeez sortie tablier
village Jia a éclaté de rire pour
un soutien de nuit propose également un lama
sous-tendu apprendre  sur vos épaules si une
relation littéralement d'inertie est une
pieuvre de ventilation contre le mal
Bonhomme de de da livraison mais une
fée ouais alors j'ai rencontré une nouvelle en première page
d'aucun ami ed LoCascio
Je ne révèle aucun substitut avec le jeune
jeune BFS un long voyage pas de vanille  pas
réservé de le peser sur la Côte-Nord
avec l'UEM nous avons décidé d'aller aussi pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé
dans les années 1970 l'église a sonné
sans équivoque dans les communautés intérieures
de la Côte-Nord donnant le Canada à l'
opposé de Marie Immaculée un ordre
créé en  Il y a deux cents ans en France,
les premiers missionnaires sont arrivés dans le
pays en 1841 avec pour objectif la
conversion des peuples autochtones à
commencer par les enfants et les pensionnats
[Musique  ]
les omelettes imposent le catholicisme et un
silence strict c'est dans ce contexte
que Robert Dominick alors
conseiller de bande apprend de ses amis émiques du grenier la
règle paternelle arrivant de
mana 1s vient j'ai jamais vu une place
sous portées tout le monde a vu un autre personne
à faire  est-ce que toute enquête comme vous faites
quelque chose oui, nous avons calculé si vous
avez tous échoué, il a signalé un accord,
nous sommes à peu près sûrs que si vous présentez des
excuses, pensez qu'avec l'économie, il
n'y a aucune preuve supplémentaire que tous abusent sexuellement de
quiconque pendant son bref séjour à
pesum it mais notre enquête a conduit à
la découverte de trois autres agresseurs
ici le sikhisme donc 10 CC par jour un peu de
poésie bétail ça reviendrait subtilement
Cleary
Michele est la soeur de Robert dès l'âge
de sept ans elle a été abusée par trois prêtres
en personne ça oui  trois tous opèrent des
missionnaires les pellets ne sont plus
le secteur des services hôteliers d'aujourd'hui elle les
enseignants étaient une femme de haut niveau vous
savez que vous connaissez Morty là ils sont un
officier de pignon fait le bo  ok Pinot
politique anna falchi viens solo l'esprit
pinfinity photo tres no Panetta photo
PDF je traite sur sidwa
[Musique]
Sylvio Lesage
le pretre photographe a laisse sa marque
une autre femme aussi apres lui homie
travaille sur boo-boo Imam besoin plus loin
la terre etait secret  satyre coulomb wha
disparaître depuis apparu s'aime
aussi Soleil vie quotidienne
P it a Darian une philosophie Santi une
zone choisie proxénétisme un polype décent
apparaît très phallique particulier massif
dollars un autre
non j'aime avec l'atomique Oh arrive l'
obscurité des sous-sols comme celui-ci tandis que
l'église au-dessus apporte et Divine Light
Yagami société Brasilia Medina gris Dini
grand supérieur né dans des
souvenirs de films porno la demeure Kazama Sunderman
Lelouch
zowie nous invite dans sa hutte de sudation
où il pratique des rites anciens longtemps
interdits par l'église
mademoiselle abusive avec mon sharpie et elle a
dit  supposons que dejan facile à vendre reporte à
proximité immédiate un espace familier pour
confier ce que le shampooing Haumea lui a fait
le  même un shampoing qui a agressé
Rochelle Babu rattori pour lui effet
sans certain ms2 stérile même en
félicitation gravité tibia joie j'ai servi la
messe pour 10 centimes par service sceau de ville
tu comme un cauchemar un prêtre en remplace
un autre et les abus continuent quand je
me rebute  pour une bouchée de manger du saumon
Jeep déshonorante en reporter ce
recours savonneux sans tache sacristie même Java ou
busca très certain d'annotations si piquantes
disparaissent Salah abandonné
dans certains en ligne où les gens Viper une
personne dont je me souviens un soldat vito rizzuto
David Tutera Zoe dit à son grand-père
qui se termine mal par une marge libre face
à face s'il vous plait Felicia je l'avoue mais
confesser le monde blasphème
verset 2 Quirino OPA dele pointe les femmes
pour le point vanille est plus tard envoyé à
Natasha Wan où il restera pendant 30
ans
son influence est encore palpable aujourd'hui
une fois dans  un bureau un je sens que la communauté est
divisée ceux qui veulent parler disent qu'ils
sont intimidés par ceux qui sont encore fidèles à
Lapointe
c'est seulement derrière c  portes perdues que
victimes et témoins me diront que
le prêtre a payé des petits garçons pour le
masturber certaines personnes seront une
victime confirme qu'il a été payé par les
prêtres dans les années 80 oui oui en 2003
le SU enquête suite à une plainte
qu'ils qualifient d'allemand aujourd'hui de social  ouvrier
pour entendre comment elle a trouvé le prêtre nu
au presbytère en compagnie d'un
jeune garçon critique elle vous attirera des
danses d'aller un défilé de mode hablo
le vêtement blanc une couverture ils sont
City Comicon schiste bitumineux ad libitum donc
soupe chanson Joseph ricotta  Kiev dans six
région bien que les Condors le Setai
Piave le fest il n'y ait pas eu d'
accusations criminelles déposées le
père Lapointe a décidé de rester avec le
soutien des anciens mais deux ans
plus tard l'applet supérieur et l'évêque
de Rimouski sont venus le chercher joint par
téléphone à son  le père de la maison de retraite
Lapointe a nié toute agression sexuelle
pour mériter un plus court il était prêt à faire
une entrevue devant la caméra mais le chef du
bureau d'Ovilus Québec  a émis une
directive selon laquelle personne ne doit parler aux
médias après des tentatives répétées de le
joindre par téléphone par courriel et en personne le
père semblait avoir refusé de faire une
entrevue wasup Madhu tanam un autre dans une
nouvelle communauté un autre prêtre problématique
une autre plainte à North Bay  a déclaré
O'Connor présenter un nouveau cancer des robots
concerne tous mes pouvoirs et les Taussig
ne sont pas communautaires c'était en 1970 les anciens
de la communauté ont envoyé une jeune délégation
pour rencontrer l'évêque et se plaindre de
la politique du missionnaire ou du maire et de son
comportement avec les femmes et les jeunes  les filles les
jeunes ont vieillis depuis que jaha a fait un
AVC mais vous vous rappelez avec
amertume sous mandat non non donc Pavo
elle est restée et a continué à terroriser les
petites filles pendant des années
il lui donnerait des lifts après la messe alors qu'un
net relate quelques oeuvres caritatives pour certains
bizarres  voix à moins que je ne sois ici, nous
ruinons la célèbre illusion Toshiba palapala
désolé commander un examen que vous savez déduit le
massage que toutes les autres femmes ont partagé avec
moi bien plus  histoires graves d'
abus sexuels commis par ce prêtre chez un
plombier qu'elle a finalement quitté pour vivre à
Québec avec une femme inny a joint
mon téléphone il refuse de parler avant que des
accusations ne soient portées une fois de plus les
autorités religieuses ont été avisées et encore une fois
elles n'ont rien fait
les révélations ont commencé  ici à Malu
tanam lors de l'enquête sur le
service des femmes autochtones disparues et assassinées à l'
aube,
mais celle que vous allez attendre
profitez des témoignages abondants
Alex numéro de non est accusé d'
avoir agressé des dizaines de personnes pendant plusieurs
décennies dans - dans de nouvelles communautés sur le
nord le courage dont font preuve les femmes
oblige Jove news doit parler
ensemble me confondre avec l'argent car
la famille tu sais
l'homme était-il un peu abusif sur un serveur
après avoir obtenu son diplôme en Belgique en 1981 elle
est allée rejoindre et aider son oncle  L'
affirmation de Sadiq oh la saviez-vous que
sa sœur prend contact avec vous pas de
commissaire équitable SWAPO presque TT - Karen -
Wagner Ted connaît les gars de connotation dans
Universel honnête ouvert bien non certains
interdits il ne donnerait accès qu'à la
monodie parlante à avorter Jin Hans est
ascétique Rafaela virgule C elle
échappe enfin à son oncle tend la main à travers des
lettres d'une centaine de pages qu'elle
nous donne comme preuve voici un
deuxième extrait de  HTML soins le sénat qui
bouddha module
il a fait le report voir diminution ou le
désir même amour est ce que monsieur a besoin d'urgence a
besoin de vous et amira
il y a un si bon quartier ici
identité d'accueil pour professeur
elle nous met en contact avec francis mac
tout nouveau d'una signifie moins cher
Le fief de Jove Noah nous l'avons rencontré à
Québec où il est soigné pour
un cancer du pancréas à 17 ans
Francis travaille pour les prêtres
illustrant des livres religieux traduits
à un plus large public sur un Sud le
panneau de particules que vous attendez voir aussi
profond après le cirque partie contagion
loin moderne HD jouer en direct 820 nous numérique
négatif 3i Morton encore Peter Thornton
elle sera affectée aucun effet néfaste
assisté robuste Emily sentir mon pauvre enfant un
psychologue
non d'accord la plupart de vos certitudes un Noblet
a ensuite été nommé archevêque il est décédé
en 2015 emportant avec lui les
confidences des victimes
ce n'est que lorsque jove connaît la mort que
François souffre finalement terminé après
six ou sept ans d'abus
seulement après l'enquête nationale une fois
tout a été révélé que les Oblats
émettent une communauté déclarant que le bureau est
profondément préoccupé par le
témoignage entendu Jaffna est enterré parmi
les Innus qui débattent maintenant de l'exhumation de son
corps et de l'expédition de ses os vers les
hautes terres dans un manga dans un autre dans la nouvelle
applet du cimetière Honda  Looney veille
sur ses fidèles avec Simon se reposant pour l'
éternité à côté de son agresseur le mana être
ludique je me suis moqué de toi mais dont l'art
un imam maltais devait les Simon avait
confié son histoire à sa tante mais l'
obligeait à garder son secret pendant des années
semblait un très le  même responsabilité
sama si moche la secrétaire épididymaire
aujourd'hui elle révèle l'ampleur des
abus subis par Simon alors qu'il était encore  juste un
enfant ça
m'a laissé couper l'aluminium c'est le matin ça a
commencé dans un pensionnat où le
père dallona a enseigné en 1967 il est
nommé curé de mango equina
cheat aux USA ouais non la pépinière est-elle
juste assise
Luis une clé de véhicule abugidas aha
clé macoco compte tenu de sa pitié pour la poursuite de l'
affaire clé devenue nous incapable de vivre dans le
même village que son agresseur Simon a quitté
méga après le lycée pour leur grande
ville et l'oubli induit par la drogue
[Musique]
les violences sexuelles du père de Launay
c'est avec John Marshall  Dean on
comprend parfaitement c'est un homme brisé par ses
multiples tentatives de suicide qui l'était
malgré sa détresse jean-marc comme tous
les autres a voulu se libérer de son
fardeau et dénoncer ceux qui régnaient sur
leurs âmes et leurs corps et c'est
grâce à leur  des témoignages que notre
enquête a découvert 10 abuseurs de capacite
regardez ces photos de cette période, peu
importe la moitié des personnes présentes
parmi celles dénoncées ici pour
agression sexuelle  ted in New Energy chemic
laboured Rijn prêtres qui bénéficiaient de
la protection de leur congrégation se
souviennent du père poule ikutsu caché en
France pour ses supérieurs qui était devant
huit garçons de femmes qu'elle a finalement
porté plainte à la police il est le
seul des dix vers le haut  pour faire face à des
accusations en 2004, il a été condamné à 15
mois de prison qu'est-ce que cette personne a
envoyé sur mobile PDG Kim ils l'ont fait
est devenu ce matin c'est ce qui a poussé Jason
à briser son silence pasteur ma ma loge
m.  kilo si je sortais avec peut-être certains utilisateurs de
Street Alley répondent étouffés - alors j'ai
trouvé un
homme sérieux fongique exhale la personne
Alex et Arthur étaient parmi ceux qui
déposent une plainte à ce jour, leur
identité était protégée par une ordonnance du tribunal
qu'ils voulaient lever pour
parler  dehors ouvertement sévère même si
j'aime livrer de l'argent
Najma pardonnez-moi pardon
venez sur notre hostilité à embrasser les
enfants du KGB sans défenses marquer à vie
laissant les femmes tushy trans coucou l'
aîné a expliqué que les enfants à la
chimie signifie peu de lumière regardé un
wagon est lavé à Magnus  Lumiere le
Kouhei a
rencontré le tribunal et le mot prêtre
flamme noire
vous ne pouvez pas inventer cet homme Aragua la
prune vous êtes en zone détenue il a
renvoyé le titre Apache dans l'air à ce
stade je serais typique
l'évêque
[Musique]
[  Musique]